- [Interviewer] All right, Crystal.
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Crystal,
where did you grow up,
where are you from originally?
- I was born in Ohio, raised in Virginia
and raised back and forth
between Ohio and Virginia,
for a minute.
- [Interviewer] You grew
up with both your parents?
- No. I grew up with my mom.
And then I think I was
about three years old
when my grandma got custody of me.
No, I was four, that's right.
I was four years old when
my grandma got custody of me
for about five years.
- [Interviewer] Why'd you leave your mom
to go to your grandmother?
- My mom had abusive boyfriends.
I was one years old when she threw me
out of a second story building
due to our beds on fire,
me and my brother.
She dropped my brother down,
my brother was like six years old,
and she literally tossed me out the window
due to set our beds on fire.
- [Interviewer] Who set your bed on fire?
- My mom's ex-boyfriend, Bob I believe.
It was just too much,
after Bob it was Mike.
Mike beat us pretty much for
everything under the sun.
I remember getting my ass whooped,
my butt whooped, sorry, for-
- [Interviewer] You can swear.
- I didn't touch a bug.
There was a dead bug on the
floor and I didn't pick it up.
And I got my ass beat,
with a power hose, innit.
I was six years old I think for that.
I don't know, it was crazy.
- [Interviewer] So a
lot of physical abuse?
- Yes. A lot of physical,
a lot of mental too.
Being called names, told
that you're worthless.
The whole nine and it
just never got any better.
So we went and moved with my grandma.
- [Interviewer] No sexual abuse?
- Not until I lived with my grandma.
When I moved in with my grandmother,
I was with my grandfather.
He molested me pretty much
from about the time I was three
up to about the time I was seven.
I guess the sad part
about that is my mom knew,
my grandmother knew and all my aunts knew,
because he did it to
them when they grew up.
I'm the only granddaughter
out of my whole family.
It's just me and all my boy cousins,
they never experienced that.
My grandfather didn't touch them.
I remember he would get mad at me too.
It was crazy, he would get mad
and I'd go tell everybody in there
and they wouldn't believe me.
They already knew that happened though,
so I just don't understand
why they let me go through it
the way they did, but-
- [Interviewer] With
a childhood like that,
where did that take you as an adult?
- Wow, that's a good question.
I actually met the father
of my children at a bar.
We have three boys together.
My oldest is 16, and my youngest is nine.
Throughout that
relationship he was abusive.
He used drugs really bad
and hid them from me.
I think going through what I
went through in my childhood,
it reflects on the men that I pick now.
Because every relationship
I've been in has been abusive.
That put me in a bad spot.
I use drugs...
As a comforting mechanism.
I can't handle it when I'm not high,
it's overwhelming, I wanna give up.
- [Interviewer] And what is your drug?
- Heroine.
- [Interviewer] Heroine?
- I use heroine, crystal, smoke pot.
- [Interviewer] And
where are you living now?
- I currently live on
the streets here of LA.
- [Interviewer] On Skid Row?
- Yes. I don't have a spot exactly,
because all my tents get stolen.
My tents get stolen like clockwork,
so I gave up on having a spot,
I just bounce around from spot to spot.
Go around to people I know.
- [Interviewer] And how do
you support yourself now?
- I panhandle.
I fly a sign on a corner,
I ask people for money.
I get rejected a lot, like a lot.
I'm lucky to make 10, 15 bucks a day.
But it's life.
- [Interviewer] You're not doing
what some of the other
girls will do for money?
- I have.
I'm not gonna lie.
I'm not gonna sit here and lie, I have.
But that was only when
I was really hard up.
I'm the type person...
I treasure myself.
I did anyways, I'd rather
go out here and work
my hands dirty and make money,
instead of sell myself
because that's just not
in the cards for me,
it don't work for me.
I've done it once, maybe twice that's it.
I couldn't do it, I felt degraded.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, I think
it affects everyone that way.
- Yeah, so-
- [Interviewer] Whether
they realize it or not.
- Yeah, it just is not for me.
I'll go out here and paint a
house or wash somebody's car,
mechanically work on something.
I've got mad talent,
it just goes to waste.
- [Interviewer] Do you have kids?
- I do, I have four.
Three boys and a girl.
- [Interviewer] And where are they?
- My three boys are currently
with my ex mother in law down in Florida.
They're pretty much
the only family I have.
My entire family passed
away last December.
December 11th is my mother's birthday,
the father of my children...
My mom passed away
December ninth last year,
and the father of my children
passed away December 11th.
Then my brother killed
himself on December 12th,
and then my dad down here,
my biological father,
he died December 17th.
And then my best friend,
I was in a relationship with him
after the father of my children,
he passed away on December
20th, all last year.
- [Interviewer] Wow.
- I hate to say it, but I
really haven't mourned that.
I haven't mourned any of them yet.
I've just kept myself high.
My daughter's three, she's down here.
She's actually about
four blocks from here.
- [Interviewer] Who is she staying with?
- She stays with this older couple.
I met the lady online
through a pen pal thing through my email.
And I've been talking to her
for probably about six years.
And she told me her life story,
she was in a car accident,
couldn't have kids.
And her husband was looking to adopt.
I found out I was pregnant,
and as soon as I found out I told her.
Because I'm living on
the street, I use drugs.
I can't have a kid out here.
And I told her about it
and I got myself clean for that year.
I maintained the pregnancy
and she came out beautiful.
She's healthy, she's
an amazing little girl.
And I signed her over to
them immediately at birth.
And I think that was
probably the best thing
I could do for her.
She's a little angel.
She's beautiful.
She's like somebody plucked
her off a store shelf.
She's just fucking beautiful.
And she's amazingly happy right there,
I could not have made a better
choice for her as a parent.
People might call me a shitty parent
for that but I don't.
If I was a shitty parent
I would've done drugs
and kept the baby living on the streets,
that's a shitty parent.
Giving her a life though,
that's a good parent to me.
- [Interviewer] What's the
hardest part of your life?
- Being away from my kids-
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- My three children,
I was with them from
the time they were born.
I was a stay-at-home mom,
I loved being a mom, bro.
My kids are everything to me.
And it sucks I have no
contact with them now,
because of my drug use.
And that hurts.
That is definitely the
hardest part of my life.
Because I've been out here six years,
almost seven years now.
I'm stuck.
- [Interviewer] Do you see any
hope of getting out of here,
getting clean?
- I hope so.
As of right now, I can honestly say no.
I can't see that in my future.
Only because, like I said, I'm stuck.
I'm a heroine addict.
Until that drug stops, I can't go home.
They're being well taken care of,
I'm very grateful to my mother in law.
That woman has earned
so much of my respect.
She's number one in my books, bro.
Hands down, she's amazing.
She's raising three of my children,
she's doing something that I couldn't do.
And I'm highly grateful to her for that.
- [Interviewer] You went
through a lot as a child.
Is there something that
you would pin point
as the main reason that you're
in this predicament today,
that happened back then?
- My mother.
That's baseline, my mom
was a shitty parent.
She chose men and the bars
more than she chose me and my brother.
My brother practically raised me.
My brother is the one who told me
about woman having a period.
He's the one who taught
me how to use Kotex.
That's crazy, I blame my mother.
My mom is the reason that
my kids were taken from me.
All because I did not order her food
correctly over the phone.
She called Children Services
and she trashed my house
and told them that I smoke
pot and they drug tested me,
and seen my house all dirty
and they took my kids.
Because of her.
I blame my mom for every
situation I'm in right now.
I know that's not cool to say,
but that's the truth.
I'm not gonna sit here and lie to nobody.
My mom is definitely the
baseline of my problems.
Definitely, but it hasn't been
easy for me out here either.
Its just as hard, I have to
fight for everything I have.
My shit get stolen all the time.
I've been raped three times out here.
I've been beat up.
You name it, it's happened to me.
- [Interviewer] It's a rough neighborhood.
- But hey, I'm still alive and kicking.
The worse thing I got is a scar.
It's not safe being a single,
white bitch out here in
California on the streets.
I make it happen though, no matter what.
- [Interviewer] What do you worry about?
- What do I worry about,
out here on the streets-
- [Interviewer] What's
your biggest concern.
- My biggest concern in life period,
is not making it home to my kids,
or making it home and them rejecting me
for me being gone for so long.
I'm terrified of that.
- [Interviewer] Is shame a big part of-
- Extremely. I'm ashamed,
I'm disappointed.
It's almost like a disgrace
to my relatives to my family,
for me to be out here.
I'm very ashamed to be out here.
I'm a certified genius, bro.
I have a certificate.
I was in the Air Force.
I went to nursing school, I'm an RN.
I'm a certified RN,
but I'm out here on the
streets doing drugs.
It's a fucked up thing.
- [Interviewer] What's
the most important lesson
that you've learnt in your life?
- The most important
lesson I've learnt now is
if you have good parents
or people who raised you,
respect them though.
Have that respect for your elders,
give them the appreciation
that they deserve,
because not many people get that in life.
A hard lesson I've learnt
is don't judge people.
You don't know anybody's story,
everybody has one.
Everybody has a story.
Don't judge anybody by a cover.
Because you don't know what
they went through in their life.
- [Interviewer] All right, Crystal.
Thank you so much for sharing your story.
- No problem, man.
- [Interviewer] I wish
you the best of luck,
I hope you get back to your kids.
- Yes, sir. Thank you.
- [Interviewer] Thank you.